mankind that's present State has been
around for a quarter of a million years
he had only the last four thousand have
been of any significance so what we do
for nearly 250,000 years we huddled in
caves and around small fires fearful of
the things that we didn't understand it
was more than explaining why the Sun
came up it was the mystery of enormous
birds with heads of men and rocks that
came to life so he called them gods and
demons and begged them to spare us and
prayed for salvation in time their
numbers dwindled in our numbers rose the
world began to make more sense when
there were less things to fear yet the
unexplained can never truly go away as
if the universe demands the absurd and
the impossible mankind must not go back
to hiding and fear no one else will
protect us we must stand up for
ourselves while the rest of mankind
dwell in the light we must stand in the
darkness to combat it contain it and
shield it from the eyes of the public so
that others may live in a sane normal
world we secure we contain we protect